i promised my accountant i wasn't gonna
take my rap money and by jury
i don't know if i lied to her she lied
to me but
i'm doing a lot now
what's up gq this is saint john and
you're finally watching on the rocks
a lot of leather pants
[Music]
in my neighborhood all the rappers and
drug deals that jewelry i didn't see it
growing up it's not like i saw like my
uncle
all of my uncles what's the statue of
limitation on some of this
i'm talking about
this i like this is my favorite i don't
want to have favorites i don't want to
be one of those parents that
chooses one of their kids as their
favorite but this is my favorite i don't
care what y'all
talking you see all the detailing the
hand engraving you see the skulls
that repetition is just sick the
oxidization
i don't even know if that's exactly what
it is but i like saying words that
people aren't familiar with
it was oxidized google it we got this
from
thailand we have to import it i found it
online and i was like this this is
special
this was before i even knew what chrome
really was
is one of my favorites although you just
heard me say that's my favorite
it's favorites for different reasons
that's my favorite for aggression and
this is my favorite for my childhood
dreams
you see my adult dreams my childhood
dreams
my adult dreams my childhood dreams my
childhood dreams with platinum
my adult dreams are silver this is the
rockefeller chain this is a rockefeller
pennant
the last original one at least that's
what biggs told me he didn't rely on me
so
one of my very first earlier moments in
making music i was listening to volume
three jay-z
i remember watching religiously him on
the steps wearing the rockefeller
pendant
and that culture being from brooklyn
that's everything if you got one of
these around your neck you're somebody
that somebody should
biggs gave me this the night i was
leaving to go to guyana to go see my mom
the government everything was shut down
and he said he ain't going to wait no
longer because
life ain't promising time is short he
left the room and i cried i ain't gonna
lie i cried for like 15 whole minutes
straight quote me on it i feel like i
ain't spending enough time telling you
what this really means to me
this needs its own 45 minute segment
don't expect me to give you some sort of
fanciful
quotation that's gonna help you
understand what this means this is the
whole culture
these are all the hustlers that made it
out kept their word had integrity
this 12 year old me you did it same
baby saying you did it
these are some of my favorite necklaces
this is a chrome heart piece
these are rubies a gold necklace it's
really delicate it's just fine
i'm ignorant but i'm not gaudy i just
want it to look the way i want it to
look
i'm not gonna pull up at the club
expecting you to know what this is
that's the point if you know what it is
you know what it is and if you don't
then that
really really sucks for you
all right so this right here i think
they would call this a tennis bracelet
but it's a necklace or a tennis necklace
with a little teddy bear i was in post
malone's house at coachella
and his jeweller came open this was
about like a couple years ago
and i was like yo let me see that teddy
bear they thought i was nuts because
that's not the first thought y'all don't
think the guy from brooklyn from east
new york wants the teddy bear and i
definitely did if you don't like teddy
bears you overly aggressive and if you
overly aggressive i don't want to have
dinner breakfast or lunch with you
sit down somewhere in the back not close
to me
chrome hot dice these are silver these
are my celeron dice
this is not semi-precious stones these
just like bejeweled
they look cool it's all the four and six
up
and it's how i got my high school money
[Music]
pay me what you don't pay my money pay
my mother [ __ ] money
four four six
don't try zoom in fam i want the money
leave me alone
here's another one of my chrome heart
pieces this is a bracelet
so it's like interlocking hearts i think
that's what it's supposed to be i don't
got to know the meaning or the
definition behind all of these things i
just gotta love it
and i love this oh i like silver i like
silver more than i like any other
precious metal
just because it says taste just because
it says design
it doesn't say flex it says quality
i always wanted a gucci link but to get
my gucci link from gucci is pretty cool
the minute he told me was sterling
silver i said ooh take my card
take my platinum card another chroma
piece the minute i find somebody who's
good at making silver designer silver
i'm in we could be best friends
these aren't silver i don't think this
would feel too good in my mouth if it
was silver
these are white gold i just wanted them
to look like they've been lived in
like i was a pirate from 1402
but i had better skin than a pirate
this is my black sabbath frank i just
like it because it's ignorant
i'm from brooklyn i should know not
about black sabbath right this is a
three-piece ring
just goes on a thumb i take a lot of
inspiration from the way that women wear
jewelry
women wear things in a more bold way a
little bit more fearlessly than men do
there's no gender to expression it's
just what you think and what your taste
decides
uh you know what i'ma stack them up so
you can see what they all look like when
it's happening in real time
this set of four the color changes these
are semi-precious stones
rubies sapphires and all the other
semi-precious stones that are beautiful
i'm st john thank you guys so much for
checking out my dainty jewelry
collection yeah dainty
i'll see y'all next time by the time you
see me next hopefully i'll have my god
complex medallions
my mom will be back in america and i'll
maybe let's shoot this in guyana i'm
gonna shoot this in guyana next i like
that
let's shoot in guyana